this is what victims have called a day
of reckoning for the catholic church in
france the scale of sexual abuse by the
clergy exposed hundreds of thousands of
children exploited thousands of priests
betraying the trust of their
congregations
and for those who suffered at the hands
of priests it's a day which has been too
long coming
it's been haunting me
all those years and now i'm
really
i'm not completely freed about it but
i'm in that process the church has to be
accountable now for for all what she's
done over these years
a massive report spanning 70 years
concluded more than three 000 children
were victims of sexual abuse within the
church wrongdoing which catholic
authorities covered up in a systemic
manner decade after decade simply
turning a blind eye
it's a scandal which has to be
confronted according to this priest who
has dealt with abuse victims he says
they're left scarred for years
some factors are well known and no
real measure were
taken
to
overpass
this big problem
especially in scholar institutions
and
maybe the priest will be changed from
another parish or another school
and the problem
came back
the pope said he received with sorrow
what he called the news of the terrible
reality and the church needed to embark
on a path of redemption
the report follows a recent scandal in
france where now defrocked priest
bernard pranar admitted abusing more
than 75 boys over decades he was jailed
for five years it has taken the catholic
church in france much longer than other
nations to confront the true scale of
sexual crimes against children and the
tragedy for many surviving victims is
that their abusers are now dead only 22
cases which can still be pursued have
been passed to prosecutors
the reporters made 45 recommendations on
how to prevent abuse including the
training of priests rebuilding
confidence in the clergy may prove a
bigger challenge
michelle clifford sky news france